[Musique]
avec michael et demi d'euros bonsoir sa
grève de la rédaction de tv 78 retour
sur les résultats sportifs du
département ce week-end et on commence
par du football avec une rencontre
internationale
c'est ça c'était la fête dans les
tribunes du stade mob auront de
versailles dans le cadre de la trêve
internationale la guinée et les comores
se sont affrontés ce samedi en match
amical
une rencontre inédite sur cette pelouse
qui a plutôt l'habitude de voir évoluer
des équipes de nationale 3 on écoute le
président du club de verser au micro de
patrick jacques de dixmude
c'est festif ça fait vraiment plaisir de
voir de voir le stade et les tribunes
pleines et une ambiance chaleureuse
voilà qui les gens qui viennent
supporter leur sélection ça fait
vraiment c'est vraiment sympa d'y jouer
en ile de france y joue plutôt souvent
en espagne en afrique de bruxelles
c'est la patrie ça n'a pas de prix on a
près à n'importe quelle distance
vous venez il a boosté pour la petite
histoire les comores l'ont emporté sur
la plus petite des marges sur le score
de 1 but à 0 vu le succès rencontré pour
cette affiche la ville de versailles
n'exclut pas d'organiser d'autres
rencontres internationales dans les
prochaines années
toujours en football mickaël il y avait
de la coupe de france ont joué ce
week-end le 5e tour et lé club yvelinois
n'ont pas été à la fête
voici s'est incliné à 2 à 0 face à noisy
le sec où il s'incline également sur cet
écart face à adamois château a été sorti
aux tirs au but par mots après un match
spectaculaire ponctuée par un 3 3 seul
versailles échappent à cette journée
noire les versaillais l'emportent 1-0
sur le terrain de courcouronnes genre de
la cité royale connaîtront leur
adversaire ce jeudi à 17 octobre et qui
continue donc une série d'invincibilité
depuis février du rugby pour terminer le
championnat de fédérale 2 les plaisirs
on a réussi à tenir en échec
gennevillois sur son terrain lors de la
4e journée du championnat
score final 20 partout un résultat qui
permet à plaisir d'occuper la 9e place
sur 12 avec un bilan d'une victoire un
nul et deux défaites depuis le début de
la saison
l'objectif du club reste le maintien à
cette saison on continue à parler de
rugby mais cette fois ci dans le
championnat de fédérale 3 versailles
fait du surplace les joueurs de la cité
royale promu cette année dans cette
division n'ont pu faire mieux que match
nul ce dimanche à domicile contre
vincennes lors de la 4e journée
résultat qui n'arrange pas les versets
qui pointe actuellement à la 8e place
avec une seule victoire au compteur on
écoute le responsable communication du
club pierre chevènement et sûrement
encore un peu tôt pour pouvoir tirer des
conclusions parts on a eu que quatre
matches en tout cas on est dans on est
dans la réalisation de ce long parce que
longtemps en fait c'est que il ya une
vraie différence entre l'honneur
régional de la fédération au niveau
national en état d'esprit une façon
brute à faire évoluer à chanter merci
michael ces informations et d'autres
résultats suivre dans votre émission le
7-8 sport dans quelques instants sur tv
78 avant de refermer ce journal une main
dit sous un chapiteau 400 fidèles et ont
assisté samedi au cirque europe a
installé en ce moment attrape une
célébration spéciale et des numéros
d'acrobaties et de diabolo ont été
exécutés pendant des psaumes chantés
voilà c'est la fin de ce journal belle
soirée sur tv 78